PS there's no secret encoded message
that means something else love Taylor
Taylor Swift just dropped her 10th
studio album midnights along with a
music video for her track anti-hero this
song really is a real guided tour
throughout
all the you know things I tend to hate
about myself we all hate things about
ourselves and um
and it's all of those aspects of the
things we dislike and like about
ourselves that we have to come to terms
with if we're gonna like be this person
and of course the swifties are all over
decoding its Easter eggs wait wait wait
wait wait you guys there's probably a
secret encoded message that means
something else now we're breaking down
all those secret encoded messages I know
that I have a habit of dropping cryptic
Clues and Easter eggs when giving you
information about new music and I'm not
here to deny that but I am here to defy
that starting with the cowboy
[Music]
hats
the first ghost Taylor encounters is
wearing a cowboy hat a potential nod to
her past in country music
foreign
[Music]
country music then there's the red
sunglasses I wake up screaming from
dreaming
another ghost is wearing these iconic
heart-shaped Shades originally seen in
the Grammy winners video for her song
22.
[Music]
and don't blink or you just might miss
the ghost wearing cat ears like the ones
Taylor rocked in 22. I'm smart and I'm
hard working and we're just getting
started with the callbacks to taste
catalog she gets struck with a bow and
arrow in her dining room an apparent
reference to the archer off of 2019's
lover album and pause right there now
zoom in and you'll see Taylor's emblem
on the wine bottle which we've seen
before in the music video for lover
the crest features the number 13 in
Roman numerals a snake a butterfly and
three cats you know that's what's
happening here this is how he prefers to
travel and that photo on the wall that's
a snap of Marjorie Finlay Taylor's
Grandma an opera singer who inspired
songs on Evermore watched as you signed
your name Audrey all your closets are
backlog dreams
at another point in the music video
Taylor steps on a scale with a younger
version of herself watching in
disappointment as the word fat flashes
Taylor opened up about her struggles
with an eating disorder in her 2020
documentary Miss Americana I tend to get
triggered by something whether it's a
picture of me or I feel like I looked
like my tummy was too big or
or like someone said that I looked
pregnant or something and that'll just
trigger me to just
starve a little bit just stop eating
then after Taylor sings she has a dream
her daughter-in-law kills her for the
money we meet the daughter-in-law in
question who has long curly blonde hair
and is wearing a very familiar dress and
Kimber you're literally wearing her
clothes right now no I'm not that's from
The Fearless tour 2009. yeah her name is
Kimber which might just be some subtle
shade towards Kim Kardashian whom Taylor
has had long-standing beef with ever
since Kim's ex Kanye West name checked
her in his song famous I feel like me
and Taylor might still have sex why I
made that famous oh and it's worth
mentioning Taylor dropped her new album
on Kim's birthday so whether she's
referencing past feuds or old music it's
safe to say No One Drops an Easter egg
like Queen Taytay
[Music]
times
[Music]
[Music]